questo video potrebbe sembrare ha
certamente idiota lo so che non ce ne
sono stati intelligente ancora ma è
sempre meglio avvisare prima di
iniziarne uno
ciao a tutti allora avete fatto caso che
in tutti i blog tv myspace facebook ma
manca in testa msn le persone in fondo
su tutte quante fighissima dei pezzi di
modelli usciti da non si sa dove
certo se sei un rito senza antifurto
nemmeno la foto alla francia riuscirà a
coprire gli occhi a palla che escono
tipo tipo prua del titanic e dall'altra
parte dell'iceberg nome ognuno sembra
riuscire a fare una cernita tra le 2000
foto che si fa per riuscire a beccare
quelli 2 nelle quali assomiglia
vagamente un po a breve un po angelino
insomma un po a questi qui
[Musica]
oppure ci sono le riprese strategiche
dall'altro dove l'occhio solamente o
proprio l'intera capoccia con i piedi
sotto al mento che sbucano così tipo do
do dell'albero azzurro per fare per
capire ciò che è che ormai capito come
funziona se quell essere che aveva
chicche un pennuto a pois con un tipo le
gambette attaccare sotto al becco doccia
può essere che non ricordi io male
mentre si che poi immagino questi qui
cioè cosa fanno per farsi queste foto
tipo si buttano se si favorisce navali
si si si si si circondano di scarpe
perché molti se ne fanno queste cose le
converse all star che che sono coperti
tipo tipo american beauty né coperta di
rose questi coperti le scarpe sono
rapido ranco banco nelle favelas ci
stanno queste cose che sembravo i libri
i poveretti che si caldo che non hanno
le coperte con gli usano le scarpe di
rifiuto dei decreti
i padroni delle piantagioni di marijuana
a del brasile certo mi si potrà pure
dire che arte o che semplicemente in
quel giorno volevano fare un palco col
con tutorial vi giuro di gelo che ci
sono persone delle quali mese dopo mese
segue lo sviluppo delle loro chiome nel
senso cioè però queste chiome che
crescono crescono poi vengono tagliate
perché è giusto questo ti fanno vedere
una persone delle quali non si sanno
ancora i colori almeno gli otto per per
capirci che poi se fossero intelligenti
non è che verrebbero a dirti a pezzi che
sono carina beta e cioè allora grazie lo
sa lo sa cioè pensare che sono senza
trucco vabbè tra c'è un pochino l'ho
messo nel senso giusto nello chino di
fondotinta è giusto paga paga matinée
guarda un pochino si nota però
tranquilla cioè ferrero bene così è
giusto è giusto bilancio ma ecco cioè 3
fine non è da zocca voglio dire
altra cosa esperienza mi ha insegnato a
capire una grande lezione il senso tu
vedi queste foto tutte figli se magari
anche è sentito i tuoi incontrare con le
persone e sono tutte quante fighissima
magari ci stanno quindi quattro foto
tutte quante straccia straccia di tutto
quanto
e poi ci sta una foto dove sei un cesso
[Musica]
secondo me quella pure se l'unica foto
su cinque è quella che rappresenta di
più la persona come nella realtà quindi
prima di uscire con una persona così in
appuntamenti al buio
voi andate carini succi controllatevi
fate tutta la lista quella quella dove
sta più sesso
allora allora è lui o lei poi ci stanno
quelli va bè che c'è se toccano su
photoshop c'è poco da fare ma che c'è il
nasino di brigitte bardot alla
francesina e poi te li trovi invece maga
magò con la patata dopo la mia
preziosissima direi perla di saggezza
cinese delle delle 6 melo 6 dell'esempio
diciamo che posso per andare ad azionare
la stanza con il minimo di onore che mi
è rimasto e al nome anzi io adesso
sapete che faccio più ad alzare una foto
al ginocchio nella pende un fronte bada
rimorchi a giro